au parc de la coulée verte les
spectateurs s'installent dans l'herbe
munis de chaises de plaids ou encore
deux coussins pour cette première séance
le public est au rendez vous plus de 840
4 entrées ont été comptabilisées au
programme le film
iti un classique pour commencer la
deuxième saison du cinéma en plein air à
la commanderie on est venu en famille
avec les enfants on a trouvé ça
sympathique comme idée c'est la première
fois qu'on vient et donc on est venu
avec les enfants tout une tout en
famille pour voir un film qu'on a vu
quand on était petit voilà on est avec
nos cousines et notre tata pour regarder
un film en plein air ah oui c'est la
première fois et on prend l'air en même
temps de regarder cinéma c'est agréable
quand on a voulu aller voir le film
hitch y est
l'année dernière on y est allé et on a
comme ça nous a plu maintenant on va
essayer d'y aller chaque année pour
faire patienter le public
l'orc est l'harmonie de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est joint à l'événement pour
faire profiter d'un interlude musical
[Musique]
des fous trucks sont aussi présents pour
ceux qui n'avaient pas prévu de pique
nique
les films sont on a essayé de les
choisir vraiment pour soi familiale ce
soit des comédies des comédies qu'on a
pu voir des films et historique des
adaptations littéraires mais qui reste
assez facile d'accès pour que ce soit
mme un public lambda qui puisse venir au
cinéma tranquillement la nuit est en
train de tomber il ne manque plus que
l'écran géant qui est gonflé quelques
minutes avant le début du film pour les
prochains rendez vous du cinéma en plein
air les yvelinois pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir le grand bain charlie et la
chocolaterie ou encore little miss
sunshine